erinnern sie sich auch so gerne daran
wie wir gemeinsam 2008 die hypo real
estate bank gerettet haben mit fast 17
milliarden steuergeld aber das war es
wert denn damals haben wir das zocken an
den finanzmärkten ein für alle mal
beendet wir wollen nicht schlecht so
immerhin wurde dem ehemaligen hypo real
estate georg funke in diesem jahr
endlich der prozess gemacht wegen
geschönter bilanzen höchste zeit wie
geht es dann aus wie viel jahre kriegt
er am zwanzigsten januar dieses jahres
beginnt in münchen der prozess gegen
funkel wegen bilanzfälschung fast zehn
jahre nach dem beginn der krise jetzt
ist der prozess auch schon wieder zu
ende
das gericht hat festgestellt dass es
nicht mehr rechtzeitig vor der
verjährung fertig wird einfach mal
früher anfangen
tja da ist es wohl für georg funke in
dubio pro ge auf meine damen und herren
seine anwälte haben das verfahren mit
immer neuen beweisanträgen so in die
länge gezogen dass er jetzt aus der
nummer raus kommt ja funkel lebte
zuletzt fröhlich im sonnigen mallorca
und er will auch noch eine abfindung von
3,5 millionen euro plus eine rente von
47.000 euro monatlich verzichten kann
ich auf etwas was mir zusteht bestätigen
wir doch erst mal von seiten der politik
dass es mir zusteht
gebt mir einfach mal geld user ein typ
zum knuddeln das blamabler ende eines
prozesses und wie die kollegen bei
aktenzeichen xy sagen würden leider kein
einzelfall
das eigentliche problem das eine problem
ist nämlich der eklatante personalmangel
an deutschen gerichten deswegen haben
die kaum chancen gegen große
anwaltskanzleien wie im fall funke
hunderttausende fälle liegen
unbearbeitet auf halde
während unsere politiker gleichzeitig
über mehr sicherheit im wahlkampf lagern
hier die sächsische polizei ermittelt
seit jahren gegen eine rechtsradikale
hooligan gruppe es gibt ohne ende
beweismittel aber wer soll das alles
lesen
das sind so um die 162 160 bände akten
drin lang stehen diese kisten hier
stehen schon etwas länger kann sein dass
sie bald hin und hergeschoben worden
sind wo gerade platz ist ach komm
schweiß alperen die blaue tonne da vorne
wo die ganzen nsu akten drinliegen kein
problem kein vorwurf jetzt an die
gerichte bei denen müsste der
personalschlüssel dringend erhöht werden
stattdessen wird ernsthaft gespart alte
regel wenn ich für etwas weniger geld
ausgeben wird es hätten besser nur in
der justiz und den zugehörigen
politischen verantwortlichen ist das
noch nicht angekommen
mit unserem justizsystem würden wir
nicht mal mehr in die eu aufgenommen
werden
mein gott wir sind was das heißt wir
sind quasi griechenland
ist ja nicht übertrieben und klar
weniger polizei das kriegt jeder mit das
sieht man auf der straße wenn man sich
umguckt aber sparen bei gerichten das
feld erstmal nur wenigen menschen auf
bis 2032 gehen rund 40 prozent der
deutschen richter und staatsanwälte in
rente ja fakt und und viele werden nicht
ersetzt
sehen sie jura secure es ist egal
[Applaus]